the one thing that makes developers
different than the common people out
there is the command line the moment
someone opens up a terminal and types
out their first command they're
instantly transformed into a jedi hacker
in today's video we'll take things to
the next level by building a crazy
command line tool from scratch in fact
you can try out the app we're building
right now by running npx fire quiz from
your terminal that's because i deployed
it to npm as an executable and i'll show
you how you can too now i realize that
people will bash me for not using bash
in this video but the node.js ecosystem
has all kinds of awesome tools that can
help you build an over-the-top command
line tool that'll make people think
you're some kind of coding wizard if
you're new here like and subscribe then
the first person to win the game of who
wants to be a javascript millionaire
gets a free fire ship hoodie let's first
take a look at what we're building today
we have a command line tool that
animates the text who wants to be a
javascript millionaire then it will
prompt you to enter your name after that
it goes through a series of multiple
choice questions when you enter an
answer it will show a loading spinner if
you get it right it will continue but if
you get it wrong it will exit the
command line script and call you a loser
if you make it all the way to the end
you win it will show you some ascii text
with a color gradient and a message that
when left in the comments on this
youtube video wins you a free hoodie to
get started with this tutorial create an
empty directory now go ahead and open
that directory in vs code then run npm
init flag y that will create a new
package json file where we can install
node dependencies now i have a list of
packages to install here and i'll
explain what each one does as we get
into the code inside the package json
we'll want to change the type to module
doing that tells node.js that we want to
use esm modules allowing us to use the
import export syntax instead of the
commonjs require function now let's
create an index.js file for the source
code and inside of it the first thing
we'll do is add a shebang at the top
you'll always want to include one of
these when writing a command line script
for somebody else to use it tells the
operating system to execute the code
with the node.js version installed on
the user's local system from there i'm
importing all of our dependencies and
the first one that i want to show you
how to use is chalk which is created by
one of the most prolific open source
creators out there syndrasaurus an
actual codewizard its purpose is very
simple it will color the output text in
the terminal there's also a popular
alternative called colors.js but its
most recent version is known to have
some pretty strange bugs and bugs so
strange that they got put on the news so
you might want to be careful with that
one chalk has a bunch of built-in colors
and to change the color of some text all
you have to do is wrap it in the color
that you want or you might use a
background color at this point let's
test it out by opening the terminal and
running node index.js or just node
period and the result should be the
highlighted text colored text is cool
but what's even better is animated
colored text a package that builds on
top of chalk called chalk animation
allows us to easily create a rainbow
animation and a bunch of others as well
in the code here i'm creating a global
variable for the player name then an
async function called welcome the
welcome screen will animate the text who
wants to be a javascript millionaire now
in the terminal we can only do one thing
at a time and to display an animation
we'll need a couple of seconds to show
it to the user to handle that i'm
creating a helper function here called
sleep it takes an argument of
milliseconds that defaults to 2000 and
then resolves a promise with a set
timeout you'll see this code in many
javascript code bases because for
whatever reason javascript doesn't
implement a promise based timeout in any
case we can now call await sleep inside
of our function that allows the rainbow
to animate for two seconds and then
we'll call stop to move on to the next
step where we console log the actual
instructions for the game you'll notice
i'm using backticks when console.logging
which creates a javascript template
literal a template letter allows us to
interpolate values into the text and
also create multi-line logs without
manually including line break characters
now let's go ahead and call our function
but let's also include the awake keyword
in front of it that may seem strange
because we're using a weight outside of
an async function that's possible
because node.js supports top level of
weight in fact we could probably write
this entire app without defining a
single function and just use top level
await for everything but i do think
named functions makes the code more
readable go ahead and run the script and
you should now get that cool rainbow
animation now we're going to take a look
at another very popular library used in
many command line tools called enquirer
its job is to collect user input and has
a variety of different ways for doing so
to collect the user's name we'll first
create an inquirer prompt which can be
customized with a variety of different
options you'll first give the data a
name and then the type specifies how
that information should be collected an
input is like a form that the user can
type into you can also do things like
validate the input or provide a default
value as we're doing here now when the
promise resolves it will return the
player's name which is assigned to the
global player name variable now go ahead
and run that function with top level
await and the command line should prompt
you for some input now the next thing
we'll do is use inquirer to create
multiple choice questions for the quiz
this function will work in almost the
exact same way the only difference is
that instead of an input we're now using
a list which has multiple choices to
choose from now we'll need to handle the
ui differently based on whether or not
the user selects the correct option for
that i'm creating another function
called handle answer that takes a
boolean as its argument inside the
function we'll create a loading spinner
with a package called nanospinner that
will run for 2 seconds while checking
the answer if the answer is correct then
we can say spin or success and move on
to the next question otherwise we're
going to say spin or error and then call
process exit with an argument of 1. when
a process exits it usually has a code of
0 or 1. 1 means that it exited with
errors 0 means everything was fine and
what it will do is just kill the script
right away let's go ahead and run that
function and you should get a multiple
choice question that when answered
correctly will give you a green check
mark and when answered incorrectly we'll
give you a red x now all the other
questions are implemented in the exact
same way so now let's implement the
screen for the winner the function will
clear the console's current output and
then format a message called congrats
player name here's a million dollars
we'll then pass the message on to figlet
which is actually a javascript
implementation of a popular program
implemented in the c language what it
does is generate ascii art from text
which is really useful for making your
non-programmer friends think you're some
kind of genius on top of that let's make
it look even more spectacular using the
gradient string package it's kind of
like chalk but instead of a plain color
it creates a color gradient and now we
can await each step in the process for a
complete command line tool it may seem
trivial but knowing how to build your
own cli tool can be extremely useful for
productivity i do it all the time for
personal projects and for clients now
the final thing i want to show you is
how to share it with the world via npx
it's actually really easy all you have
to do is go into the package.json and
add an entry for bin that points to your
index.js file from there run npm login
you'll need to have an npm account where
you can publish all your useless
packages then run npm publish to push
your code to the cloud congratulations
you just deployed a beautiful command
line interface thanks for watching and i
will see you in the next one